مصادر امنيه عراقيه تتحدث بان القصف
استهدف مقار لفصائل الحشد في قضاء القائم
على الحدود السوريه هل من توضيحات
اكثر نعم سلمى بالفعل اكثر من مصدر اكد
لنا ان هناك بالفعل استهداف لهذه المقار
مقار الحشد الشعبي في القائم وتحديدا في
منطقه السكك وايضا المقر العام لقياده
الحشد الشعبي في تلك المنطقه ايضا الك
كتيبه المدرعات 13 وايضا مخزن للاسلحه كما
فهمنا في منطقه العكاشات اذا هناك استهداف
كبير في عده مناطق ومصادره ايضا سلمى
بالمناسبه تتحدث عن استمرار هذه
الاستهدافات اي انها لم تتوقف بعد ويبدو
ان هناك اهداف اخرى ستضرب ربما في هذه
المنطقه طبعا لتوضيح للساده المشاهدين
القائم هي في اقصى غرب العراق وتحديدا على
الحدود السوريه منطقه قريبه جدا حتى اننا
يعني كنا يعني او كان الكثير من الذين
تحدثنا اليهم كانوا يعتقدون ان هذه
الضربات هي في سوريا على اعتبار ان المكان
قريب جدا وهناك اماكن قريبه في داخل
الاراضي السوريه ايضا تم قصفها وبالتالي
الان يمكننا ان نؤكد بان هناك بالفعل قصف
استهدف مدينه القائم مراكز تابعه للحشد
الشعبي في القائم هذه طبعا للتوضيح ليست
المره الاولى نعم على ما يبدو ان هذه
الضربه كبيره لكن هذا هذه المنطقه استهدفت
في اكثر من مناسبه اخر مره استهدفت فيها
منطقه القائم كان في ال4 من الشهر الماضي
عندما قصفت مقار للحشد الشعبي
واقتل شخص او احد اعضاء احد افراد الحشد
الشعبي واصيب اربعه في هذا الاستهداف الذي
كان في القائم اذا هذا هو الاستهداف
الثاني وبدايه استهداف العراق كما ذكرنا
في المقابلات السابقه يتوقع العراقيون ان
يكون ربما الضربات ان تكون الضربات الاكبر
هي هنا في العراق على اعتبار ان حزب الله
العراقي على الاقل امريكيا هو المتهم
الاول في استهداف القاعده الامريكيه ومقتل
الجنود الامريكان الثلاثه